welcome everybody I'm extremely excited
to be here
this afternoon in the the final talk
session before our wrap-up keynote which
I'm personally very excited about I hope
you are too
and I think that if over the past couple
of days probably a lot of us have gone
to some pretty intense technical
programming talks and I hope to make
this talk a little bit of a palate
cleanser and try to get us into kind of
engage our brains in some playful
thinking and maybe you know kind of
think about some fun things like puzzles
and video games that are a little bit
less intense than some of the
programming talks we've seen so far I
will talk about programming a little bit
at the end of this talk but sit tight
for that if that's what you're here for
so I'm presenting how to think like a
system puzzles problems and programs and
I want to start out by kind of priming
your brain a little bit hopefully I can
hear some audience responses because I'm
actually going to ask you for the
answers to some things so I'm gonna
present to you a class of problems
called Vanguard problems and these were
invented by a Russian computer scientist
in the 1960s Mikhail Hosea vich Bongard
for studying things like pattern
recognition and they were later State
studied in a thesis by Harry found a
Lowe's who studied under Doug Hofstadter
whose writing is influential for the
title of this conference strange loop so
a little bit of a connection there so
the way Bongard problems work is they
show you a collection of examples on the
left and a collection of examples on the
right and your job is the puzzle solver
is to figure out what rule distinguishes
these two sets of examples so we'll
start with a fairly easy one you've been
looking at the slide for a few moments
now who can tell me what the rule is
that distinguishes these examples I'm
hearing some people say triangles yeah
okay so we've got triangles on the left
and quadrilaterals on the right now of
course there are some other features of
these shapes the fact that some of them
are filled in and some of them are just
outlines there
to size and position within the squares
that represent the individual example
but none of those features happen to be
the distinguishing characteristic
between the two sets of examples okay
here's a slightly harder one I'll give
everyone a few moments to look at it and
then don't shout it out I'll call on
somebody to to tell me what the
difference is in this puzzle yeah yeah
so the unfilled shape or the white shape
on the left is a is sort of overlapping
the black shape and then on the right
the opposite relation kind of holds
between the two shapes so that's the
answer for this and I'll show you one
more example which again is I think for
most people kind of increasing along the
difficulty scale a little bit but I will
give you a little bit of a hint which is
that a number of you I know are
interested in recursion so there might
that might be a relevant property to
think about with respect to these
examples now don't shout out the answer
I'm actually not going to give it so if
you would like to think about this for a
moment maybe take a picture of the slide
if you don't quite see it yet that's
cool if you want to talk to a neighbor
and ask them for the answer that's also
totally fine all right
so if you'd like these kinds of problems
like I said Harry found a list word a
dissertation about them and also
maintains an online index of Vanguard's
100 original problems that took this
form and then also another hundred that
he and other researchers developed on
their own okay so with that in mind I'll
now give you some of the context for Who
I am and what I'm talking about here so
I'm an assistant professor in computer
science at North Carolina State
University and I started there a couple
years ago and began my lab my research
lab which I call poem 4 principles of
expressive machines and this is my third
Strange Loop Talk sorry not my third
talk but my third time at Strange Loop
and when I was here in 2013 five years
ago as a PhD student I was giving a talk
about linear logic programming totally
different concept a totally different
topic from this one however that doesn't
form the kinds of things that I
do and we'll be talking about today I
love functional programming logic and
proofs my research these days has more
to do with kind of applying those things
to creative disciplines so designing
tools and languages for things like
interactive narrative video game AI
procedural generation and system
modelling more generally and lately I've
been really puzzling over kind of what
you might identify as the relationship
between two subfields of computer
science human-computer interaction and
formal methods or programming languages
and I've been thinking a lot about how
we can relate these things on the Left
which I'm calling experiential
characteristics to formal descriptions
to mathematical models of a system that
someone is in interacting with so what's
on the on the left over here is examples
of things like the emotional state that
someone might be in when you you have
you create a well-designed video game
for example it's supposed to connect to
this psychological idea of flow where
you're doing something challenging but
you're doing it well or when you're
reading a story or it even perhaps more
silently and interacting with an
interactive narrative you experience
some dramatic pacing in a certain
narrative arc that affects the way you
feel or the the lower-left example there
is Bloom's taxonomy which relates to
education how do you interact how does
interacting with a system teach us
something not just imbue us with new
knowledge but actually give us new
skills that we can go out and apply for
example programming and so I kind of
call this this question this is like
area of exploration human system
interaction sort of refined
human-computer interaction I'm using an
example of a video game on the right
because what the point is here is that
there's an actual formal system somehow
that we can identify and describe in
formal ways and try to identify some
relationships between the definition of
that system and the way people relate to
it and interact with it so how does this
idea kind of correspond or relate to
Bongard problems well something that you
may have observed is the Bongard
problems take a little bit of a
different flavor from a lot of standard
puzzles
or problems if you're given a problem
set in a class or you're trying to solve
a problem a lot of that tends to be
you're taught some rules or you're
taught some algorithms and you're just
going to apply those to the new cases
that you're studying on the other hand
Bongard problems are kind of going the
other way around they're saying well
here's a couple of examples that you
know some things that follow this rule
some things that don't and your goal is
to actually identify the rule so that
process might remind you of a few other
things that humans and computers each do
typically independently so things that
humans do include hypothesis driven
science a kind of kindergarten model of
the scientific method wherein you make
some observations and based on those
observations develop a hypothesis and
say okay well I think that the rule is
this as soon as you observe something
that doesn't follow that hypothesis
then you revise it right and you come up
with a new hypothesis another thing that
you might relate to is test-driven
development the idea that before you
write a line of code you give a sort of
approximate specification of what you're
doing by providing some input-output
examples for a program and then say okay
now I see how to generalize those
examples to the kind of code that I need
to write other things that might come to
mind include example driven program
synthesis kind of a related idea to if
you were Nadia Polikarpov --is talk on
program synthesis there's a certain
related line of work in which you're
actually feeding the synthesis algorithm
input output examples and then it's
trying to learn how to come up with the
the program that encapsulate the most
general version of that behavior and a
sort of similar idea of course that's
gained a lot of traction recently is
data trained classifiers giving a
certain system a bunch of examples of
you know pairing an input data with
annotations and then having it develop a
sort of black box model where you can
feed it new examples to get new
classifications so my question here is
how we can enable humans and computers
to best collaborate with one another to
do things like this together so these
include things
you know how do we design games it also
includes how do we design code editors
interfaces and programming languages
that basically enable this kind of
human-computer collaboration so with
that I can outline how I'm going to talk
about that problem and the first thing
that I'm going to do is set up a general
theory sort of from cognitive sciences
about mental models and then I'm going
to show how you can apply that theory to
make sense of a kind of taxonomy of
things across the spectrum of puzzles
problems and programs and then I'm gonna
speculate a little bit about how we can
do some of this tool design that sort of
how we can enable these processes to
work better so let's start here so first
of all what is a mental model we throw
this word around a lot casually I think
when we talk to each other
they're the Cydia kind of came about
from a cognitive psychologist or
cognitive scientist johnson-laird in
1983 in a book titled mental models and
he tried to identify okay like what
distinguishes a mental model from just
any other kind of knowledge well it is a
knowledge structure but it can
critically do two things it can predict
the outcomes of certain situations or
actions and it can explain those
outcomes after the fact and the way it
does this the the theory is is kind of
that we have a miniature version of an
external reality kind of living in our
in our thought processes in our mental
simulation so again using the example of
a level of mario video game we can
imagine this this game we imagine a
version of the level where in whatever
rules we think are currently applying
are going to apply forward and we're
going to be thinking about what's about
to happen before we see it happen in the
external system so zooming in on this
particular example of super mario
brothers level 1-1 which is a sort of
staple of video game design kind of
study because it was the first of its
kind in a sense it was addressing a new
audience of video gamers who had never
seen anything
quite like it before and so it had to
establish new conventions what we now
think of as a standard trope this kind
of idea of platformers and collecting
coins and so on you know the developers
had to really work to establish the
kinds of things that players were seeing
for the first time and get them used to
this language of jumping around and
doing things in a virtual world so if
you're interested in this level in
particular in the in kind of this design
idea there's a great YouTube video
diving into what the designers did to
facilitate this convention and kind of
get people on board with what you were
doing in this game what I'm gonna talk
about instead is just kind of the
process that someone might go through if
they're encountering this for the first
time sort of cognitively so the first
thing you do is you have a controller
and there aren't that many things on it
right there's like four directional
buttons and an ax B and if you start out
in this situation where there's a lot of
white space over to your right
and you're facing to the right so you
might think okay I'm gonna go right so
how can I do that well I'll press the
right arrow that seems fairly intuitive
okay Mario's going right what did these
a and B buttons do okay well a seems to
make me jump great so you sort of fiddle
around and you get a little bit of a
mental model establish that there's some
directional movement there's jumping
there's gravity that kind of thing and
you have established a mapping with the
controls the next thing that happens is
you see some little angry mushroom kind
of thing appear to the right of the
screen and you notice that it's heading
to the left towards you and you're
heading towards it and based on your
physical mental model you might think
okay well I'm about to collide with this
thing I don't know what that's going to
do if it happens then in fact Mario will
die and you'll have to restart the level
oh no it's not that big a deal you
didn't get very far if that happens so
you just restart and try again
okay but now you've added something to
your mental model that's great okay
you've learned something that you didn't
know before when I collide with a
mushroom thing I'm gonna die so in the
process you might subconsciously or not
also make a generalization that you know
kind of based on this visual pattern
recognition idea
that you know hey that thing would
shaped like a mushroom and it was bad
for me so I'm gonna make a rule I'm
gonna generalize what I just saw to just
assume that maybe colliding with all
mushroom shape things is bad maybe I'm
gonna die well the very next thing you
encounter is an actual mushroom and it
looks kinda like that and so if you
apply your mental model in this
particular case you might think okay
well I'm gonna collide with that
mushroom that might make me die but when
you do it in fact Mario gets bigger
which is a good thing in the game so
what has to happen is you eliminate the
assumption that you had made the this
generalization that your mental model
made turned out to be wrong there was a
different mushroom shape thing and it
didn't make you die it made something
good happen so if to make a finer
distinction and revise your mental model
to say okay well okay colliding with an
angry mushroom makes me die colliding
with just a regular mushroom is fine it
makes me big so to summarize and kind of
extrapolate this whole process mental
models are a way of simulating external
realities in our minds they make
predictions and explanations about
what's going to happen when we do
certain things to interact and they
generalize from examples sometimes those
generalizations are wrong and they can
mental models can be wrong in general
and they can revise upon failure so I'm
currently playing a difficult platformer
game called Celeste that was released
this year which is really fun but you
die a lot there's lots of spikes
everywhere and it gives you this little
message sometimes it keeps track of how
many times you die and it says be proud
of your death count the more you die the
more you're learning keep going I love
this as a life message but I also love
it I also like it as it applies to
mental models because actually the fact
that mental models can be wrong is not a
flaw it's it's how they learn it's um
how they develop and become in closer
alignment with the actual system model
that's making things happen okay so
let's try to apply this now we're gonna
sort of stay in the videogames realm and
at puzzles kind of how they work in
digital games so there's a again a great
YouTube video from a game designer
called Mark Brown who has a video titled
what makes a good puzzle and the very
first thing that he establishes is that
you can't get anywhere if you don't have
sort of good enough mechanics or clever
enough mechanics and this sort of
establishes this is the mechanics of the
game or your ironclad rules they should
never change because if they're changing
then your player has no ability to
develop a stable mental model because
the things are always going to be
changing out from under them and they
may think okay well I may as well just
behave randomly because this mental
model isn't stable but so you have to
have some kind of clever mechanics and I
want to start with this example of game
called cosmic Express in which you draw
a little train tracks on a grid and
collect alien passengers and deliver
them to little matching boxes where they
will then get out and once all of the
aliens have been delivered to their
homes your train can go on its merry way
and you can go to the next level so
that's the goal if just up with some
kind of goal for the player and you have
to establish a way for them to get to
that goal so again these mechanics are
ironclad they're their rules and more
importantly perhaps there are
limitations that will never change
and so in cosmic Express this includes
things like the train tracks cannot
cross a cross over one another each
passenger has to be taken to a matching
box each train car can hold one
passenger and the passengers will try to
hop into any empty car that passes them
so using these mechanics now we can
start to build to build on them to
create kind of observe the interesting
interactions between things that might
happen in various configurations of the
level designs to set up some interesting
challenges so for example so there might
be some kind of unexpected consequences
of the mechanics including like this
example where you have a train car going
between two aliens they both try to get
at once and
neither of them can get into the train
car so those are the kinds of things you
may not expect as a player at first but
then when you see them you're like oh
okay sure that makes sense so then from
there how do you actually develop a good
puzzle on top of this foundation so
there's kind of a trifecta of things
like a pattern that you might experience
as sort of an experiential property for
a player to go through which is that you
you maybe make some assumption about how
level works then after testing out that
assumption again this is a theme of
failure comes back you realize that it's
not going to work the way that you had
naively expected it to perhaps because
that's how it worked in some previous
levels and you have to identify what the
catch is why is this level so much
harder than what you'd seen before and
then finally perhaps after struggling
for a while you have a revelation you
have that aha moment which is when you
finally realize how you can approach the
puzzle in a totally different way from
how you've been thinking about it before
so to see this in cosmic express you
might see this level though this is this
is just a still of the you know the
level you might look at it and say okay
well each passenger is right next to a
little box of the same color so perhaps
I can deliver the passengers to the
boxes that are closest to them then you
start drawing routes and trying to
figure this out
and then you notice this catch right so
three view as soon as you just try to
draw a route that takes a passenger to
its nearest box you block access so
you're your means of creating a solution
your tracks are also your obstacle right
they you run into yourself you sort of
trap yourself by encountering a
situation where you're blocking off
passages that you need because there's
just this one track with passage between
everybody so finally if you fiddle
around with it for a while you may
eventually have the revelation that you
can kind of you can take passengers to
farther away boxes than the ones that
are right next to them and so one
example when solution might look like
this undo that and then yeah so then
that top left passenger goes down there
and the bottom left passenger goes up
there so the research question here for
me is as someone looking at this as a
you know does this assumption catch
revelation pattern this is kind of a
folkloric idea of what it means to to be
a good puzzle and well does that have
anything to do with mental monologue
position does it support if we build
this this notion into puzzles of when we
design them does it support faster or
more accurate mental model alignment so
my lab built our own puzzle game that we
could kind of take apart and recombine
and tinker with to try to set up
different experimental conditions to
study this question and we built it in a
scripting language called puzzle script
which is a lot of fun especially if any
of you are kind of programming language
nerds like maybe some of you are it's a
lot of fun to play around with it's it's
a sort of DSL for writing
two-dimensional tile based puzzle games
and we built a game that has a little
bit basically it involves lasers and
mirrors and sensors and things like that
so you can spin around the lasers with
the yellow corners or sorry you spin
around the mirrors with the yellow
corners to redirect the lasers the
lasers hit the sensors and the sensors
turn on other lasers which eventually
turn on the exit so you can finally
leave with this basic set of mechanics
we can develop some sort of interesting
consequences of those mechanics and we
actually are giving them names so sort
of we name the skills that the player
can acquire after they thinker around
with the mechanics and learn certain
consequences of them so this is a skill
that we call feedback where and we
notice that if the player toggles a
pressure plate and then steps off of it
the laser can actually stay on and the
reason that works is because well let's
see if I can actually go back to it so
the the way that the the level starts
out the laser that would hit that right
hand sensor is being blocked by a door
and pressure plate will open the door
but then once the laser is hitting the
sensor the sensor actually toggles the
door as well it's a sort of duplicate
power supply for the door so it no
longer needs the player to be standing
on the pressure plate in order to stay
toggled okay so we built a we noticed a
sort of a couple of interesting emergent
mechanics like that and we developed a
sort of concept dependency tree between
them
and eventually kind of came up with some
more complex mechanics like this idea of
a beam block where and you can well I'll
show you through the animation but the
this is a puzzle that happens to have an
assumption in a catch so in this case
it's kind of similar to cosmic Express
where you make maybe make some
assumptions about proximity to where
things are and say you say you see that
mirror that you can pick up and move
which you know because it's it's got a
pink line in it the pink line indicates
that you can pick it up and you think
okay well I'm just gonna move that over
to where it's gonna make the laser
bounce off the next mirror and and then
I'll go and pick up that splinter over
in the top right hand corner and see
what I'm gonna do with that okay well I
can bring it down and redo placate sort
of that beam so now I can move my mirror
away but oh I can't use my mirror to do
anything useful because it's not
pointing the right in the right
direction for me to redirect it into
that sensor that I need in order to open
the door so the revelation is that you
can actually use these mirrors and
splitters in the opposite configuration
from what you would initially assume so
if you go pick up the splitter use it in
the place where you would pick where you
would use the mirror put the mirror
where you use the splitter then you can
use the splitter and it's more awesome
splitting capability to open the door
so after building this what we wanted to
do is to cretak kind of ask people if
they could make predictions and
explanations about what was going to
happen in these bubbles if you remember
that's what a mental model does so in
order to measure people's mental models
we thought okay well we need to ask
people for what they're going to predict
something with what they predict is
going to happen in a given level and
then let them play it and then after
they've played it maybe something
happened that they didn't expect and can
they explain the discrepancy can they
show some kind of revision of their
mental model after that process an
interesting note that I think is um sort
of false start with the study design for
this but which is I think relevant to
some of the takeaways in this talk is
that we tried initially to give people a
think aloud to just kind of put them in
front of the game
and ask them to make predictions and
explanations before they did something
in the game but they had the game in
front of them and this did not work at
all
because if you give someone a thing they
can tinker with and you ask them to tell
you what you're going to do next or
what's about to happen they're just
going to start pressing the buttons you
cannot actually get them to pause and
talk to you you could say there's an
interactive thing in front of them and I
just I don't know yet I just want to
poke things and see what happens people
get very exploratory which i think is
it's like kind of a thing about humans
and that we should like be exploiting
more in our designs but nonetheless we
wanted to we wanted to get their actual
kind of capture of their men in their
mental state before they had the ability
to act so we just showed them a
screenshot before we allowed them to
play in this study so eventually because
I'm a computer scientist and not
fundamentally a cognitive scientist my
research goal is to use what we learn
about mental model formation in the
study which we're still analyzing the
data for and eventually maybe
procedurally generate puzzle sequences
that could support this notion of deep
mastery that a lot of us find really
satisfying when we play a well-designed
puzzle game so that brings me to the
next step of this this journey which is
problems and sticking within the digital
games category again I'm gonna show you
a couple of examples of what I think of
as sort of a different class of puzzle
solving games and sometimes these are
called strategy games sometimes they're
categorized under puzzles but things
like infinite factory or factorio which
incidentally both have sort of factory
as their roots because what you're doing
is taking raw materials and assembling
them into machinery that can produce new
materials and then sort of recursively
building up your infrastructure in order
to solve certain challenges a personal
favorite of mine this is a 1993 kind of
version of us The Incredible Machine
which I grew up with is yeah so this is
another example where you're given these
kind of goals in order to
you have to make something happen and
Louisville and you've got your your your
primitive elements or things like our
sorryi things like pulleys and boxing
gloves and fire and all there's all this
stuff that is simulated by the physics
engine but you then assemble together an
elaborate Rube Goldberg machine in order
to accomplish the goal so Marc Brown
again has another great video about this
distinction which I find really useful
wherein he talks about puzzle games in a
different category from problem-solving
games because in puzzle games what
you're doing is more like discovering
the solution and in problem-solving
games you're inventing a solution and
there's of course two words of
difference there Discoverer versus
invent the versus a day so in in a
puzzle solving sort of scenario what
you're doing is essentially I like to
think of puzzle games as a two-player
game between you and the designer it's
just that the designers not there
they've but they've left you little
secret messages in the design of the
level of the puzzle and it's your job
sort of discover those messages put them
together and kind of make sense of what
they intended you to do in this very
delicately handcrafted way whereas in a
in a problem-solving game yeah if the
game designer is giving you a challenge
they've probably solved it themselves
but it might be a much wider space of
possible solutions and they may not have
explored that space very thoroughly and
perhaps they're just waiting for you to
find a more efficient solution than
whatever one that they manage to find
and so there's a lot more of sort of a
process of invention going on in
addition to the bigger solution space
this comes about as well in open world
games like minecraft where you have
materials like redstone which is
essentially a simulation of conductive
material that can be used to assemble
computers and you've also got some just
kind of more literal interpretations of
this idea like T is 100 we're in the
challenges are to literally write code
to a fictional assembly language
in order to solve challenges and there's
also kind of a sandbox mode where some
very industrious people have decided to
reemployment
using this fictional assembly language
so of course the question comes about
you know for if we're giving people
these things that are literally
programming and we're giving them in
giving people games that they enjoy and
are learning how to build robust mental
models of fictional programming language
in a game well couldn't we also use this
to teach computer science or to you know
kind of get people excited about the
idea of programming and there are some
folks in the lab adjacent to mine run by
Tiffany Barnes at NC State the game to
learn lab who have taken that idea
seriously and you know developed a game
called BOTS wherein the whole mechanics
are to write a script for a little robot
to navigate a 3d world in order to
navigate to an exit and you've got the
you've got the actions that the robot
can carry out like movement and picking
things up and you've also got looping
constructs and variables and so on and
you can challenge yourself in terms of
the efficiency of the solution or the
code size of the solution another
example of this that I personally enjoy
is this game called Cube composer
developed by thinking into the
independent developer David Peter which
teaches some functional programming
idioms were in you've got a palette of
possible transformations over on the
left and you drag them over to the right
in a particular sequence to transform a
row of stack of stacks of cubes from an
initial configuration to a goal so that
takes us back to if we zoom out a little
bit back to programs and the question of
whether what we're learning here about
interaction failure mental model
construction can just literally apply to
the process of writing programs in the
wild so at this point I've kind of
started to sketch out a spectrum right
on one end we have puzzles as you would
find in a digital puzzle game which have
a small and very intentionally crafted
solution space
you've got towards the middle of the
spectrum designed problems which could
include problems in a problem-solving
game or perhaps problems in a computer
science class that you might be taking
we're in the solution space is kind of
co-designed with the problem itself like
maybe the designer of the problem
doesn't necessarily have the solution in
mind first and then finally you've got
kind of open programming and programming
in the wild wherein you have a big
solution space nobody has designed to
the problem for you you've just got a
real problem that you have to solve and
it precedes the solution so sort of
inspecting these things as all points
along a spectrum we can sort of start to
identify some correspondences like the
idea that maybe the mechanics of a game
this idea of having a robust mental
model that never changes of the
principles underlying the game on top of
which you can build more problems
corresponds to having a good mental
model of the programming language itself
the puzzles that you can build on top of
that set of ironclad rules are sort of
like the programming problems that arise
within a certain language and then the
puzzle solutions are of course the
programs written in that language that
address the problem and just to draw
another related analogy you can even
think of the whole process itself as
going back to this idea from the
beginning of learning rules from
examples of sort of making designing
abstractions that take particular
examples and extrapolate them to
something a little bit more general so I
actually would like to thank Simon Paton
Jones for giving me this slide so this
was from his morning keynote yesterday
it's a perfect example this was a
beginning programmer who realized that
she could replace a bunch of repetitive
steps in in a program with a simple loop
so this process of abstraction is
exactly the same idea of translating
sort of pattern matching and being able
to identify okay I can represent this in
a more concise way now people have
actually done a lot of research on how
people develop mental models in when
they're
learning how to program I'm not going to
talk a lot about much of this research
is definitely out there and has been
since the seventies it's so people are
still kind of learning about this but
there there was some sort of
controversial research that tried to
conflate the idea of being able to form
robust mental models with the idea that
there are people who fundamentally would
never be able to program which they
later retracted because of course that's
nonsense but the idea of being able to
form robust mental models is still
applicable and so a lot of people have
done some follow-up research on that
which I encourage you to look into if
you're interested now these slides will
be posted after the talk by the way in
the in reality of course most of us are
coding with an incomplete mental model
of our language so if you don't believe
me look up Gary Bernhardt sweat
talk which takes some of our you perhaps
your favorite programming languages and
shows you that the you know the models
that you have of them don't always
correspond to what they actually do so
we're coding with an incomplete mental
model but nonetheless we can get by
right we can still get things done and
in fact most of our bugs come from a
poor alignment between the mental models
of our domains what we're actually
trying to represent and the the program
that's supposed to implement that that
understanding so that finally brings me
to tools for thought so I see okay it's
counting down now okay so so finally I
want to ask this question of like is it
possible for us to build tools that
communicate our mental models directly
to a system so I would argue that in
some ways we actually already do this so
whenever we write tests this is exactly
a way to say here are some examples of
what I think my input output should be
for this function count O's each test is
a communication of the mental model we
also write tests for exactly the same
reason we want mental models to fail
early we want tests to fail so that they
fail now rather than in production type
annotations are another way of being
able to express our mental models to the
system we might take a look at those
exam
and generalize to say hey all the inputs
are strengths so the outputs are its I
would like that to always be the case
and so I will encode that as a part of
my mental model that the system can
check for me
whenever we have fancier types we can
give more precise communication of our
mental models for example if we had a
dependent type system we might be able
to say that the value returned by count
OS should always be a number that's
between zero and the length of a string
we passed in that then brings us to this
concept of like well if we can express
our mental models in this
computationally understandable way can
we use tools to directly run our mental
models as programs and this inspires a
whole field that I like to refer to I
think this is a mean--it oarlocks
language of solver aided tools for
things that you know for things like
program synthesis that can take a
specification a logical description of
what we think our code should do and
just produce the code that actually does
it without us having to write the code
and then check it against a
specification I personally work on a lot
of tools that are fall under the
umbrella procedural generation and you
don't have to read this code but it's a
logical specification of some
constraints on generating a dungeon for
sort of dungeon crawler video game and
you know so it just takes this logical
specification and spits out a playable
game level so these things really
directly let us directly run our mental
models as programs I find that in
practice no because then they get big
and it's hard to tell whether they're
correct
so we've just sort of reduced it to a
new problem we're in we've now created a
very generative system that has a whole
big space of solutions and we need a way
of navigating that space of solutions
and identifying whether or not it's what
we expected it to be and potentially
changing it so finally I'll wrap up with
this idea that I've recently learned
about from David Krakauer which I find a
mentally useful when it comes to talking
about the kinds of systems I would like
to see more of in the world and it's
this concept of cognitive artifacts and
particularly a distinction between
complimentary
and competitive cognitive artifacts so a
cognitive artifact is anything that
helps us think it doesn't have to be a
real physical artifact it could be a
mathematical system like Roman numerals
or multiplication tables or it's a
system of calculus right but it's
something that helps us think and a
competitive cognitive artifact is
something that enhances our mental
abilities as long as we have it with us
but as soon as we discard it it's no
longer we no longer have that ability so
something like a calculator falls under
that category on the other hand a
complementary cognitive artifact is
something that gives us new abilities
but we can actually internalize those
abilities we've gained something new
from using the artifact and therefore
when we discard it we may not be as fast
or as accurate as we were when we had
the artifact but we still have the
ability to we have this mental model and
that's left behind that we can run to
simulate what abilities it gave us in
the first place
another example of this for me was
actually the same artifact but used in
two different ways
GPS navigation as a driver where you're
getting something that's telling you
verbally you know kind of what to do at
every turn
versus when you're using it as a
passenger or somebody walking around
kind of looking at a map and seeing
where you are you get a very different
sense of the geography around you and of
how you fit into kind of a city in a
built environment as a system when you
use these systems this way and in the
case where you're using GPS just to just
to navigate through voice commands
you're not really getting at you're not
getting a coherent map of the place
where you're navigating that you can
then use an apply after the GPS turns
off just again to tie this back into
games
I think augmented reality games like
some of the Niantic games like Pokemon
CO and ingress which preceded it are
even are another example of a
complimentary cognitive artifact in this
space that actually changes our
relationship with the system's were a
part of that can give us a new view and
kind of teach us new things about the
world around us so the takeaways here
and I'm just about out of time are that
automated system
that are really at their best automated
systems are the most awesome when they
help us develop mental models and
facilitate assess human being so that we
can collaborate better with them however
not a whole lot is known about how to do
that so if you are interested in
furthering this research mission I would
definitely invite you to collaborate
with me if anyone is potentially
interested in applying for a PhD we do
have a program for that at an NC State
and I'm also willing to talk with
potential faculty and industry
collaborators so here's my contact
information and thank you very much
[Applause]